[Applause]
be under no doubt this european capital
is fast turning into a battlefield
there are troops on street corners and
under bridges armoured vehicles
constantly crisscross the city
bolstering positions waiting for the
enemy
the ukrainian military are fighting but
they will struggle to hold on
tanks abcs and trucks maneuver beneath
the road arches
they're attempting to shield themselves
from attack from the skies
holding on until the russian infantry
and paratroopers attempt to get further
into kiev by road and on foot
well that's the expectation anyway
there's been a huge exodus from the city
those left behind attempt to thumb lifts
heading west others stop passing cars
and ask if they're heading their way
more often than not it's a fruitless
hope
the air raid sirens are irregular now
but scary stuff
with their belongings they try to hurry
off the streets
most head for the metro stations trying
to get underground
[Music]
mums and dads and their little ones
trying to find safety if they can't find
a way out
[Music]
everyone feels exposed
everyone feels vulnerable
well that's a haunting sound as uh
of uh the air raid sirens
is pushing people into taking cover just
heard a crump of an explosion
it's like this all over the city now
[Music]
his apc is up here
[Music]
exactly where and when the russians may
attack a new target remains unknown of
course so there's constant movement
[Applause]
much of the city is now deserted hardly
any people in the centre of town just a
few cars driving between homes or
looking for a few shops that are still
open
and on the streets as well civilian
militia armed and ready to support the
army
huge explosions woke everyone in kiev as
the russian mission continues
fiery debris falling onto residential
buildings below
this is life in kiev now the country's
president making exactly that point
it happens in europe not just in ukraine
when missiles kill our people it is the
death of europeans i demand greater
security for europe greater protection
for ukraine as part of a democratic
world
many of the ukrainian soldiers are very
young and inexperienced
21 year old sergey petrashenko is the
only soldier guarding a footbridge
he has fired 16 rounds in his life
now he waits for the russians
his home village has already fallen
there are a russian base in my village
and
from my village they're gonna
go here on kiev
to capture it
yeah it's really
scary and terrifying i am
called to my parents
they
really scared
there's russians in our village enemies
there's
tanks
heavy vehicle
i hope that
they will be fine
in their thousands they descended on the
central railway station trying to get
seats on any train heading south
guards firing into the air trying to
maintain order
it rarely works with people already
traumatized
it was chaotic and desperate but that is
what it's like here now
the fear of the unknown is what's so
difficult for the people
ukraine is holding its breath
while the world watches on
stuart ramsey sky news